- I'm here with singer, songwriter
and man of the people, Luke Bryan.
Twitter launched some deep
and meaningful questions our way.
And right now, Luke and I
are here to catch those.
Get it 'cause he fishes.
It's awesome, we're funny.
And we're gonna give them
the proper answers they deserve.
This is another round of
Kelly's Quaran-Twitter Questionnaire.
(upbeat music)
Here's how it works,
I will read some of the
most pressing questions
we found on Twitter during the quarantine,
then Luke and I will help
out with the answers.
Our first on today's Twitter questionnaire
comes from @Ms_Austin2_U to you who asks,
"If you could get an
unlimited supply of one item
what would it be?"
- Give you one guess.
- Beer?
(laughing)
- It's a tie between
beer and fishing lures.
(laughing)
- Fishing, I was gonna say fishing.
Mine is, mine is I don't
care what people say,
they could claim that this is two,
but it's not it's one
because I never want one without the other
chips and queso.
So, so yeah, that's mine.
- That is, you know what I had.
So I had dinner the other night
and then my son,
after his baseball game
wanted to go
to have Mexican
and I'd already had
dinner and I still ate.
- Like a fat.
- A ton.
- Yes.
- I mean, you cannot not eat it.
- It's irresistible.
It's so perfect.
It's so great.
Okay, cool.
The next one is from @Templ,
"Which artists do you want to see live
when all of this finally blows over?"
- Well we were talking about this.
Maybe I wanna go see the
boss, Bruce Springsteen.
I'm, I've been through quarantine
I've really been honing my my boss,
you know, my boss skills.
I've been, I've been,
don't be surprised if at
my next show I'm, I'm,
I'm ripping, you know,
I've got a few moves onstage.
- Yes.
I love that.
Actually I'm gonna go to that,
I want to go with you and
your wife to that show,
that sounds fun.
I've never seen him live.
I'm such a fan
and I've never seen him live.
- I think.
- I'm dying to to do it,
I gotta do it.
- I have met him and he was super kind
and so is his wife,
but I, but I, yeah,
just super talented guy.
What a, what a legend.
Okay, I have time for one more.
- All right.
- Or you have time for one more rather
So this is the last
quarantine Twitter question
and it comes from
the appropriately named
account @AskTwitter,
"What useless talent do you have?"
- I can,
I can lay on a wooden floor
and make fart noises with my back.
(laughing)
And they are,
- This is the greatest
useless talent.
- They will stop,
They will make them stop the room.
- Oh my God, that's awesome.
I'm just gonna try that the
next time I'm on a wooden floor.
- It's good.
- I only have one useless,
I mean, it's not useless I guess.
I can, I have the worst memory,
Like especially if I write the song,
like since I began singing,
like in junior high,
I just have the worst memory.
I just don't yeah.
And so I make up words
the last, the last second,
I'll just make up words
and nine times out of 10,
it rhymes, doesn't make
sense, but it rhymes.
(laughing)
And I do it often.
There's a whole blooper website about it,
but yeah, that's a,
it's a talent,
but it's useless I should
just know the words,
but I'd forget them.
Do you ever do that?
Do you forget the words?
- Well the only time I'll forget the words
when I'm in concert is if
I'm reading someone sign.
- 'Cause yes it distracts me.
Yeah.
- Like somebody like, if they go,
if their sign says,
I love you Luke like.
But if their sign has like
some interesting message that,
you know, my mother saw you in, you know,
my mother saw you in 1999
and she wants me to tell you
and like, and I start reading it,
then I'm like, I'm not,
I like my brain is gone.
I'm like.
- That happens to me all the time
and that's when I move into this mode,
you're sing.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- All right, it is always good to see you.
Please say bye to Carrie,
if you can hear me,
I love your manager.
Hey y'all, y'all stay
safe and stay healthy.
And is, it is always nice
to talk to you, Luke.
And everybody Luke's new album is out now.
It's called Born Here, Live Here, Die Here
and for Luke's special
jalapeno margarita recipe,
which I want as well,
head on over to our Facebook page.